Let's look at some tradeoffs in random testing, and what I really mean here is
advantages and disadvantages of random testing that might lead you to spend
more or less time doing it and so on this side I'm going to put advantages.
Over here, I'm going to put some disadvantages.
One of the main disadvantages of random testing is of course this something you spend
a lot of time already dealing with is that the input validity problem can be really hard,
and a lot of people would give up on random testing.
In my opinion, give up on it too early before they've gotten good results
and often it's this input validity problem that stops them.
The fact is there might be some creativity required to get around this.
For example, mutating existing inputs or getting a good enough understanding of the structure
of the input that we can actually generate valid or random inputs from oracle.
Oracles are hard too--so again, we need a substantial amount
of creativity to deal with the lack of oracles.
One of the people often like when doing testing is they like to have a fix test suite,
and they like to run it and they like to know when it's done,
but if they didn't get any failures, they can feel good.
Random testing on the other hand has no stopping criterion,
and so for example, if you run a random tester on eight course for a day without finding any problems
that implies nothing about what you'll find in the future.
You might find six or seven problems in the next hour of testing,
and in the process of doing this compiler testing that I've been doing for several years now,
I found this to really be the case.
I can start a compiler testing run. For example the weight exertion of GCC and all of them.
I won't find anything for a long time, and I think to myself--
gee, they've really sort of nailed the issues and then just as the probability is working out, how they do,
a bunch of problems will come out after a day or two.
So another problem and this one we haven't really talked about yet
is that random testing may find unimportant bugs
and what I mean by this is that since random testing explores parts of the input demand
they may not be often explored by real users of the system.
It could be that the people developing this software under test
are not remotely interested in fixing the bugs that are triggered by the strange inputs
and this can be frustrating, but it is really just very situational.
Some kind of bugs such as buffer overflows in a web server or in a pdf reader or something like that
almost mandatory to fix because they are so often exploitable.
So those kind of bugs really can't be labeled unimportant by right thinking developers
On the other hand, if we're talking about problems that really might not come up in practice
so let's say that with my C compiler testing, I generate a C function
that's 100,000 lines long and this fails to compile.
Well, the compiler developers all and certainly going to ignore me
because people just don't like code like that,
and similarly, if I make an identifier let's just say a variable name
that's 800 characters long and that crushes the compiler and they may not care about that either.
and so the general flavor of the solution to this problem is first of all to generate random inputs
that are more like inputs of interest.
So for example, when we're generating random C-codes, we don't make really long functions,
we don't make really long identifier names, we don't nest parenthesis really deeply,
and it could easily be of these things would find bugs, but we just don't really have
any confidence that if we find these bugs that anybody would care about fixing them
so we'd rather just not even find them.